- Hi.
- Oh, hey.
You wanna see my pecker?
Is that your beak?
- You wanna see my pecker?
- Is that your beak?
- You talking about your beak?
You wanna see it?
You wanna see my pecker?
[sighs]
Yeah, sure.
- There it is!
- Oh, oh, God!
- You wanna see it again?
- No, go away!
- You wanna see my pecker again?
- Shoo, leave!
You wanna see my pecker?
No, I never want to see
your pecker again!
Oh, come on,
it'll take you home.
What?
It'll take you back to your
world if you look at my pecker.
What do you mean,
"my world"?
- (roars)
- Whoa, what is that?
It's a uni-shark.
- That's not possible!
- It is in this world.
- Hey, you wanna see my pecker?
- Yes!
- You wanna see my pecker?
- You sure?
- Please, God, yes!
- Here it is.
- Where is it?
It's my beak.
[laughs]
- [roars]
- Oh, God!
Please, show me your dick!
That's nasty.
You're a pervert.
- You started all this!
- So you wanna see my pecker?
- Yes, please.
- Here it is!
Oh, oh, wha...
- You wanna see my pecker again?
- No!
- You wanna see my pecker?
Aw, come on, it'll keep
your head from exploding.
Are you serious?
You wanna see my pecker?
Oh, too late.
[laughs]